y en barcelona
forlán times
de star
wars work getting capítulo de ellos bank
environment
bueno el problema de que sean
normalizados que hay cerdos normales con
jabalíes con dinamitas y al final es
jabalí extraño y luego qué bueno que
comen de la basura y los turistas que
vienen aquí a el punto de información
para hacer exclusión digital de sant de
comer
entonces ahí es
que dejan de ser animales salvajes y ya
campan
[Música]
opino que es malo tanto para ellos como
para nosotros fueron más salvajes al
final que está humanizando y al final
estamos
conviviendo en un medio que aquí mismo
la organización no ve no hay problema
pero hay en las carreteras autopistas y
eso sí que es un problema
[Música]
pues tuviésemos estos factores
ambientales controlados los factores
sociales controlados no deberíamos de
hacer esto que es lo que sufre de que
hay una serie de personas
se relacionan de manera aberrante con
ellos es decir
ellos al
entregarle comida del gen humano a un
jabalí lo único que hacen es provocar la
pérdida de sus instintos
[Música]